n'empêche que le parti socialiste
puisque vous poser la question il
critique et condamne et je peut vous
amener gelé dans mon dossier de
nombreuses citations d'hommes du parti
socialiste il condamne les luttes
actuelles celle de manufrance et cetera
et cetera bien celle des mineurs du gard
par exemple il est contre la lune
troisièmement le parti socialiste trouve
que giscard d'estaing en fait pas
suffisamment pour aller dans le sens de
l'alliance atlantique
alors si avec ça vous ne trouvez pas que
le parti socialiste a procédé à un
virage à droite l'eau qu'est ce qu'ils
vont nous annoncer quand j'ai dans
l'attitude du parti socialiste
la confirmation très clair qu' il y a
cette conjonction n'est ce pas d'un
pouvoir qui veut poursuivre aggravé une
politique qui veut entraîner le parti
socialiste à la mise en oeuvre de cette
politique là sur la base du consensus
dont je parlais qui veulent post à
affaiblir le parti communiste et c'est
ce qui pose comme question fondamentale
devant des travailleurs qui veulent le
changement
le problème de se donner de donner au
parti qui luttent pour leurs
revendications et pour le vrai
changement
la force qui lui est nécessaire il va la
question fondamentale si vous êtes élu
président la république monsieur marché
est-ce que vous refuserez de parler avec
ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec vous
parce que vous les critiquez parce qu'il
ya une tentative de dialogue
on appelle républicain ou pas mais de
dialogue ce que vous critiquez en
parlant de consensus
le c'est autre chose sept autres charges
ah oui ah oui le dialogue la discussion
mais à partir du moment où un homme
était du président la république où une
majorité est élu à l'assemblée nationale
il faut bien que les élus de la pelouse
de l'opposition discute avec ski ça
c'est pour promouvoir ce alors écoutez
vous êtes vous êtes terry me prendre et
c'est de comprendre
bon bah vous avez du mal
vous allez prenez vraiment évidemment
vous nous expliquer pour construire
comprenait très bien mais ça veut dire
faut dire que vous comprenez que c'est à
dire que dans deux ans on nous dirait qu
aujourd'hui on a des raisons d'en faire
quand même quand vous voulez ce qu'il
faut le dialogue la discussion mais nous
l'avons d'ailleurs c'est moi qui
pourrait faire reproche au président de
la république je lui ai écrit deux fois
pour le puits destival il n'a jamais
répondu
pour les mineurs de destival et voilà un
homme qui vient vous parler de dialogue
républicain je vous fais d'abord
observer qu'il choisit ses
interlocuteurs il dialogue avec les
socialistes
mais quand les communistes lui pose des
questions sur un problème grave concret
le problème du charbon c'est l'énergie
ce le problème d'hommes et de femmes qui
sont au fond du puits de la mine en ce
moment pour défendre cette richesse
nationale est bien le président de la
république qui a reçu ma lettre puisque
je les fais pas aimer deux lettres
puisque j'ai fait porter à l'elysée il
n'a pas cru utile de me répondre je vous
fais donc déjà observé que le dialogue
pour le républicain comme vous dites
pour le président de la république il le
mène avec des interlocuteurs choisis par
lui mais pas avec ceux qui défendent
très helmand les intérêts des
travailleurs et c'est à mon avis le
deuxième aspect du dialogue
je suis pour le dialogue mais à
condition que ça se termine par quelque
chose de concret si ces départs lot pour
des parlottes ça ne m'intéresse pas mais
le dialogue pour résoudre les problèmes
posés aux travailleurs sans emploi le
dialogue pour résoudre le problème de la
cinquième semaine de congés le dialogue
pour résoudre le problème de la durée du
temps de travail
le dialogue pour résoudre le problème de
la santé du logement de l'enseignement
et j'en passe parce qu'il ya encore
d'autres l'espion oui je suis d'accord
mais à condition que ce soit un dialogue
efficace pour résoudre des problèmes
ça c'est pour le dialogue mais le
consensus sept autres choses encore
ce que veut giscard d'estaing et il ne
l'a jamais caché- d'ailleurs
regardez à la fois le contenu le ton et
le physique du président de la
république quand il a parlé à la
télévision quand il a parlé de guy
mollet
c'est tout un programme